right then okay folks I think we'll get
started thank you all for coming and you
know we don't soon be had a boat trip so
don't panic it'll be fine my name is
Matt hello hi today I'm gonna talk about
unity for enterprise developers and
before we get started I need a bit of a
disclaimer firstly I am NOT a unity
developer but it's okay cuz I'm not an
enterprise developer either so that's
fine um I am actually so like a unity
tools developer so I don't actually
build unity games as such I've haven't
ship to unity game i but i do write and
work on the tools for unity within
writer so I work for jetbrains part of
the the sort of the rider team the
developer advocate team and I help to
work with that there so just as a bit of
a disclaimer as I'm not actually a unity
developer but I kind of still do some
stuff so what do I mean by unity for
enterprise developers I think a quick
question is anybody actually using unity
right now right yeah and that's kind of
proving my point really is we kind of
we're all done at developers you know so
we're this kind of this net conference
we all done in developers unity as a
dotnet based game engine so why aren't
we all writing unity games and it's
really being very interesting working
around the Unity space because you kind
of see that there is very little overlap
between sort of traditional Nets and the
unity dotnet world so coming to a
conference like basically get lots of
conversations about asp.net MVC core and
dotnet core and multi-platform and
containers and all that kind of stuff
and if you go to a unity conference with
game dev conference you would be
surprised at how many times test-driven
development does not come up so there's
a very thin overlap here and yet we've
we've all got sort of transferable
skills you know c-sharp is a c-sharp
game engine so we could be writing games
but the question is kind of where do we
start where how do we kind of get
started this so back up just a little
bit for those of you who haven't seen
unity which was most of you there what
is it it's a game engine
we know that nice okay but what's a game
engine then so it is something that
provides us with a sort of low-level
building blocks for creating games so it
gives us
all that we need to create some graphics
to use physics as well so things can
collide so you know when things are
hitting each other and you know when
your player gets shot and all that kind
of stuff
features for animation audio effects
explosions and fireworks and all that
kind of stuff and also interactivity as
well this is really useful what happens
when two objects do collide what happens
when your player does get shot what
happens when their hit points and their
health it's down to guess down to zero
and it's not really just games either
but it is very very popular for games
and I forget the stats now but it's
unlike you know is a very good chance
that in your funny phones right now any
of the games you've got have been
written by unity there's a huge amount
of support for mobile gaming in unity so
things like Monument Valley Pokemon go
which was a massive hit as well and the
numeric Arts Tour are all unity games
but it's not oh and it's important to
point out as well it is a con souls and
desktops as well it's got full support
for those and they're available none of
the platforms - but it's not just games
as well unity is used in movies so The
Lion King and the remake of The Jungle
Book have all used unity as part of
their sort of pre-visualization stuff as
part of the design of the special
effects they've used it for VR headsets
while they're on set is you know he's
just usually just a big green screen to
sort of see what's going on there and so
to get a good visualization of what's
happening and Disney views as well for
big hero six animated shorts where
they've used it as the actual renderer
as well everything was made in unity and
also something which could perhaps be
used for more of a sort of enterprise
kind of point of view is sort of data
visualization customer facing marketing
so you can just a promotional work here
with this nice shiny advert for BMWs
like one of those cars is is ray traced
in unity and the other one is real but
you know I have no idea which one but
also things like data visualization
augmented reality virtual reality we've
got something up here from the team was
a hackathon project to create a view of
dot memory
eita inside virtual reality which is had
a lot of fun doing I'm not entirely sure
how useful it is and it don't expect it
to ship anytime soon but it's certainly
an interesting project data
visualization as well sort of scientific
kind of idea a great example of the
internet here if you ever wanted to see
exactly how much fuel a second 5 rocket
uses in terms of elephants that's that's
what's going on there why you'd want to
do that I don't quite know but it's a
great example so what I'm trying to show
it's a really is there's lots of reasons
to try and it's not necessarily just
about games but maybe it is maybe you
want to pick up a hobby you want to do
games as a hobby or maybe even as a
change of career I worked with a
gentleman who was working in a bank he
stopped working in a bank went off made
video games has got his own game studio
and doing very nicely so maybe you do
but there's also ways of using it in in
your current roles as well so with data
visualization customer focus stuff as
well so how do I write a game in unity I
don't know I've just said you can use it
for other things other than games but
it's just gonna be a whole lot easier to
set games rather than interactive
experiences and stuff um I'm not gonna
tell you I'm gonna I've only got an hour
here so I can't really sort of sit here
and explain how to build a game here I'd
be able to show you the two circles
there and you'd be having to fill in the
rest which is all a bit much so the idea
that I kind of had he really is how to
build a game in unity that's kind of the
known unknowns this is the thing I know
that I don't know I know what to go and
do to go and find it so I conducted
Google I can find the tutorials I can
run through the hands-on labs I can
actually get going at it what I wanted
to focus on was something a bit
different so the unknown unknowns the
things I do not know that I do not know
and sort of try and cover some of the
foundational type stuff the stuff that
you pick up as you've used unity but
that is not really sort of called out as
part of the the tutorials and things so
a bit of a sort of grounding of how
things how things work so we'll start
with some sort of foundational type
stuff
and sort of state some of the obvious
kinds of things here so things that
again you don't necessarily know from
the tutorials but it's really useful so
firstly unity is the application so
unity is in control here it runs your
game the great example here is that if
you think of something like SP nets
embassy cool that's a c-sharp app that
just happens to run a website where as
unity is a game that happens to run your
c-sharp the control is kind of is
flipped there so it's very important we
are used as c-sharp developers we used
to sort of being that the whole world
and owning everything and this isn't
quite right in unity actually really
sort of useful thing to know when using
unity it's like know your place know
where you are where you fit in with all
of this um the other useful thing to
know is the unity editor is a unity
application it sounds really obvious but
it took me ages to realize that and once
you do it's like ah that makes a whole
lot more sense
everything you see in the unity editor
is unity code and that means you can
extend the unity editor through unity so
you can add extra features into it and
work with it other useful things to know
is that the core engine is native code
it's C++ it's portable it's
cross-platform but it's still C++ you
use c-sharp and mono you don't use any
other dotnet framework or dotnet core
use mono to add your game logic and you
talk to the unity API through event
essentially we invoke it's not quite but
it basically through P and VOC
fortunately you don't have to deal with
that when you're writing unity code you
work with a whole load of managed
wrapper objects but it's important to
know because sooner or later your code
is going to talk to some native code and
there is a cost to that transition so if
at some point you're concerned about
performance then all of these
transitions into native code can affect
your performance another useful thing to
know is that it is a single threaded
application more or less the API is not
thread safe everything happens on a
single thread and all of your calls
sorry as unity is updating your objects
they get called every single frame on
the main thread there so if you're doing
of work you're going to interrupt the
flow of the game so you need to sort of
watch what you're doing there
the API is not thread safe so you want
to avoid using threads unless you know
what you're doing and generally even
then you should probably avoid them
there are ways of working with things so
again if you do some long running tasks
you're gonna block the frames so you can
use something called co-routines which
allows you to back up your work into
chunks which can run in between threads
or you can also use the job system which
is effectively a wrapper around unities
native threading system there otherwise
you end up with too many thread pools
and things going on right building
blocks how do you build a game what's a
unity application game built up from and
there's a few of these kinds of things
you've got scenes game objects and
components this is a sort of hierarchy
then of how everything fits together and
then you got prefabs and assets we'll
have a look at those in a minute
scenes are very easy you can think of a
scene as a level in a game it's a level
or it's the menu options page and within
that then you have game objects and
components game objects are the
fundamental building blocks of
everything and by themselves they're not
very interesting they don't do anything
they've got no functionality by default
so they've got no graphics they've got
no interactivity no actions no nothing
so they are containers and by default
they're basically empty everything in
your game is a game object and this
includes things like characters vehicles
scenery lights all these kinds of things
they're all game objects and game
objects are hierarchical as well so if
you imagine for example a tank in a game
you've got a game object which
represents that vehicle if you've got
them turret which is going to be sort of
rotating on the top of that to target
other things that's gonna be a separate
game object but it's gonna be a child so
you've got this kind of hierarchical
structure going on here game objects are
also a container for components as well
and components are the things which add
functionality to a game object so you've
got this sort of hierarchical structure
going on all game objects by default
have one Trane's component a transform
ponent and this is giving it its
location within the world you get a
position rotation and a scale but beyond
that you have to add components to get
anything else there's a whole bunch of
different components you can add to give
different things you can have a mesh to
add some graphics so if you're going to
have your tank the actual way the tank
looks is added through a mesh you can
have a rigidbody component to give it
give it mass and gravity and physics and
things to allow it to collide with stuff
it can be an audio source and play a
sound it could be a particle system with
fireworks and smoke and stuff like that
and it can also add logic through
scripts which is really useful so the
next thing then is prefabs I'm not
getting into too much detail about this
but as the name suggests these are
pre-configured game objects complete
with components a great example again is
the tank if you've got a tank all the
different components which make that up
and all the different game objects you
can save that and he store it outside of
a scene and you get to reuse it so you
can create them sort of programmatically
through code or through the user
interface and a good example of that is
like a wave of enemies you just use a
prefab and create a whole bunch of
enemies there and reuse this information
these prefabs right let's have a quick
look so this is unity all very nice and
this is the kind of default scene that
you get to see it's sort of empty by
default you've got a window at the top
left here which is the scene view this
shows you the models that are going on
and the game objects that are in your
your particular scene down the bottom
you've got a game view and this is what
you can view if you press play this is
how the game would play and how it would
look and by default you just get this
sort of default skybox as it's called so
you can just see off to the horizon in
the top you got your hierarchy of game
objects so this scene the sample scene
has got two objects by default it's got
a main camera and a directional light so
that's all that's going on in there and
it's really quite boring and then down
the bottom here we've got three other
little tabs you got a console for giving
you debugging type information and
inspector which you can use then to look
at information about particular game
objects and components so it's actually
showing you all the components they're
attached to this game object
here you've got a transform which is the
position within the world and then the
sort of camera details as well and then
you got your project window here as well
so you get to see what files are in the
project and what we can do very easily
is create a new game object or you can
create a whole bunch of different things
we can create say for example lost it
great cube and now we'll add meat a cube
into my scene view here and I can sort
of I can rotate that or I can move it
around I can rotate if I hit the right
key there we go I can rotate around it
we can view the cube itself we have the
game object in the top right and I can
view the inspector and I can see the
transform and I can change the location
within the scene very easily and work
with it it's got a cube mesh assigned to
it I can say well okay let's change that
to be a cylinder or a sphere or I can
use some of the meshes that are already
in the projects and use something like I
was a bit small whatever that one is
let's call something what's called a
turret and we can then zoom out and you
can see that we've got now got a a
different mesh assigned to this
particular object what we can also do is
we can add components and we can add a
whole bunch of different components here
there's a whole load of things we can do
we can very easily add in a rigid body
which gives it a mass and I'll tell you
what let's let's get rid of this one
first if I what I can do at the top here
is I've got my can controls to switch me
into play mode so if I click play I
don't sort of start playing the scene
and it does whatever the scene is set up
to do and because we've got a boring
sample scene it's doing nothing
one thing I can very easily do then is
add a rigidbody component which is going
to give me some mass and gravity to my
object and if I let's make this raise up
a little higher if I press play now
what should happen is that gravity
applies and the thing Falls there's
nothing for it to fall on to so it's
just gonna keep on falling forever and
ever because it's in foreign to it but
it we can do some interesting things
there you can build things up from there
but let's have a look at something a
little more interesting so this is a
project which I've downloaded from the
asset store which will explain about in
a minute it's a starter kit and it's a
sample project which is useful to look
at and see how things are working and it
gets like a level here which you can
sort of zoom around and see what's going
on you can also see that it's got some
user interface of no idea why the user
interface is quite so large on this but
there we go in relation to the rest of
the scene but you can still see what's
going on there and you can see now we've
got a more complex hierarchy on the
right hand side there as well so we can
click on things like where am I going to
navigation objects there and that will
show me all the objects that are
selected as part of all that and I can
go to headquarters there and I can focus
on headquarters and again I can sort of
rotate around that I can see my
inspector and I can see the object again
this one's got a transform and I can
modify that and move things around but
it's not just the in sort of objects
which are sort of physical objects
within the world as well we can have
some things like configuration so
there's a wave manager here something
that controls the waves that come in as
part of this game and we have ten waves
as part of this they're all timed waves
here and these waves themselves are more
game objects of the game objects
containing data which I'm using as part
of my scene and if I double click on
that it takes me to the inspector for
this one and it shows me all the spawn
instructions there's things that will
happen when this wave fires and it's
going to spawn off enemies and I can see
that actually it's going to spawn off 60
enemies and these are the agents that
are going to use and these are prefabs
here I can select them and so I can
select where there's gonna be a hover
bus or a hover buggy or a hover tank and
once it's selected I can then sort of
double click on that too
the prefab that's there and if I show
that there we can see that that's the
object that's going to get spawned and
run with us and so if I run this now we
can see down the bottom here we've now
got our game view and this is what you
would see now is the actual game
yourself is playing and so I can
interact with it I can click start wave
and that will start things off I can
grab a tower drop it onto the thing and
you can see now we've got our enemies
spawning and we're fighting I can pause
that and now if I go to if I go back
over here I can then select my turret
and we can see that it's just another
item in the scene view is another game
object and if I get my effector there I
can change the fire rate to something
like 10 and unpause it and you can now
see that it's going crazy and it's
shooting a whole lot faster there so I
can actually modify my game objects
while the game's running and work with
my code and my game as I'm building it
all up there okay um if anybody has any
questions by the way please feel free to
just shout out otherwise I'll just keep
on going next thing I'll show you really
is the the project structure and this
again sort of underlines how things are
different to how we used to in the
c-sharp world so for example unity
projects are folder based there are no
project files as know sort of c-sharp
project files we used to being solution
files c-sharp project files and so on
this doesn't happen in the Unity world
we open up a folder and again this is
sort of underlying of the fact that this
is a unity project it's not a c-sharp
project the c-sharp is just a part of
the unity world being a full-stack
developer in a unity world means knowing
about sort of graphics audio level
design audio and music and all these
kinds of things as well rather than just
knowing about the c-sharp when you start
a project these are the three folders
you get assets packages and project
settings project settings contains a
whole bunch of configuration which is
useful things like
what targets platform you're you're
aiming for what version you're targeting
and so on and these are what you put
into source control everything else then
can be excluded when you open up a
project as a whole bunch more think
files get generated so we end up now
with a library folder and a temp folder
and also you get a whole bunch an out of
solution files and CS prod files which
we're going to be able to use to work
with our c-sharp code these are only
used by the IDE so these aren't used by
unity at all so the the generated
project files are just generated purely
for the IDE the IDE being Rider or
Visual Studio or whatever it is that you
want to use the assets folder so let's
talk about what our assets assets are
everything that you need to make your
game and there's a ton of different
types of assets from from scenes which
we've already spoken about as a
container force of game objects and
components and prefabs as well and also
you know things like models images
textures animations and so on and also
of course scripts which is very
important for our sort of interactive
data the question is where do you get
your assets from and if you're not very
good with 3d design like what I am then
what I'm not then you can also get all
of your assets from the assets store so
unity has an asset store which has got a
ton of different assets on there and it
can be anything it can be models it can
be you know sort of scenery characters
vehicles those guys things but also
games as well oh sorry not games logic
scripts and interactivity there there's
a mixture of free and paid assets
there's also starter kits available on
there you can use this just for
prototyping so it's like I want to try
and prototype a tank game so let's just
grab a bunch of tanks and work with that
or you can use it because you're not
able to design tanks at all and just use
those and ship those in the final
product one thing that's really
interesting and kind of awkward is that
when you import assets from the asset
store they get copied directly into your
assets folder so it's like they are now
your own code this has a upsides and
downsides it means you can modify things
because
you can just change things and they're
part of your project but it's also then
the downside is that it's harder to
update things because you don't know
what you have changed and what has not
changed and so on and it's also harder
to know what was originally your code
and what was originally somebody else's
code okay
civilization so some some assets are
basically unknown file types so images
are going to be pink files JPEGs
whatever same with 3d models audio and
so on and other assets are sort of
serialized information so if we're
talking about a scene for example with
all of its game objects and components
this information needs to be serialized
and saved and unity provides
serialization for us so it supports
three different sort of file formats
binary yeah Mel and Jason the binary is
now deprecated because it doesn't work
nicely with source control and yeah
Mille is the default although yeah Mel
is text-based and sort of source
controlled diffing will do things sort
of line by line it's still possible to
get into problems with source control
and the amyl files and unity has a
number of tools which kind of help with
that it's also got support for Jason if
you need to talk to web services and
things like that and if you take nothing
else away from this talk I'm gonna give
you the great fact that Jason is
actually a subset of yanil so if you
have a yellow parser you can read in
Jason so it's got nothing to do with
unity it's just a crazy fact but it's
true yeah Mel is sorry Jason is valid
llamo go figure
you've got the asset database then so
once you have all of your assets in your
assets folder those are the actual files
you're working with you know your ping
files your 3d models your audio your
scripts and so on these are stored in
the assets folder but what unity does it
imports them into what it calls the
asset database this is where the files
are converted into something which is a
game ready
format so it might not necessarily be
using the 3d model as it's been exported
out from a 3d modeling software unity
can read that when it can convert into
something that is more appropriate for
the target platform all of this is
stored in the library folder and this is
something which you can exclude and not
need
to use in in your projects sorry it's
all this stored in the library folder
and this is something which we exclude
and you don't include the source control
the key thing here is that every asset
is assigned a gooood and this is really
important and this is where metafiles
come in again this is another topic
which is not necessarily described
terribly well in sort of tutorials and
things but it's massively important
every file in your assets folder and the
packages folder has a meta file even
folders have meta files as well so if
you have a folder foo you're gonna have
a food up meta file if you have a
c-sharp file enemy CS you'll have enemy
CS meta and the meta files as the name
suggests contain metadata about the
assets that's because if you've got a
ping file for example you're not gonna
be able to store a gooood inside that
ping file so you need to have another
file which lives alongside it and the
big thing that is stored in this file is
the GU it's there so you know we've got
an example here it's all in Yammer
format so you've got the gooood which is
the key into the asset database and it's
really important and the key thing here
is really to always check your meta know
I can always always check your note even
always taking about files into source
control this is massively important if
you don't do this bad things will happen
and the reason for this is because all
references between assets is via this
good if you lose the gooood your
references are broken and your game
breaks and it's very very easy to do
this if you forget to check in a meta
file you're going to lose a reference
and things going to break so for example
if you add a script component to a game
object that script reference is via
gooood and if the meta file for that
script component doesn't get into source
control that's pointing it nothing
effectively unity won't know what it
that meta file should have been it'll
have a different good and it will break
so it's also really important to make
sure that this meta file gets kept up to
date with renames and moves and things
on and so on and that was one of the
first things that Ryder added in for
support for unity was to do that so if
you rename any any files move any files
around
ride will make sure that all those meta
files are kept up-to-date for you
right scripting but why am i calling it
scripting I've been calling it scripting
so far but that's that's not right
c-sharp isn't a scripting language is a
compiled language so why is it's why
they call scripting and this is perhaps
a legacy from Unity script which was a
another language which unity allowed you
to write your interactive logic in kind
of based on JavaScript that's no longer
support is willing to worry about that
but it's also because you get a script
like experience you get hot reloads so
when you edit a c-sharp file unity will
notice this it'll automatically
recompile it'll reload any app domains
and keep you going so there's a very
sort of quick nice hot reload cycle
going on which gives you a bit of a
scripting like experience when you
create a c-sharp script it's got to
derive from mana behavior because it's
something that's adding a behavior to a
game object and as I just been saying
all of your script components are
referenced by the Goodes of the C sharp
acid there's a bit of a quirk here
because that makes things awkward if you
reference something by a gooood that GUI
is pointing to a c-sharp file and that
c-sharp file contains a mono behavior
but when you compile your c-sharp that's
going to end up into an assembly so how
does it know what the class is because
it was pointing at a file before and so
basically you've got to have unity only
knows the name of the file and so it
uses the name of the file to know the
name of the class that was in the
compiled assembly so you need to keep
your name of the file and of the class
the same and everything will be fine
monobehaviour and c-sharp scripts give
you two main features you get event
functions and serialize fields event
functions are methods that are called
directly from native code kind of like
reflection but it's it's not as as heavy
as there is special mano API switch will
find the methods you're calling a cache
them and call them directly there are no
interfaces so everything is matched by
name only so that you've got a whole
bunch of sort of magic method there
there's a you know it feels like there's
a downside to that you can't have I
component and have a whole list of
methods that you need to implement you
just need to know which methods there
are but that's actually a good thing
because if the methods are there then
you and she's going to call them and if
the methods are there and doing nothing
you've got an overhead for no reason so
if you have if you're not using a method
you don't you don't create it and it
doesn't get called whereas if you do
need it it's there and it will get
called but you've got no way of easily
knowing what that method should be
fortunately of course Ryder will do that
well for you code completion and
inspections to make sure you've got the
right things going on there and a whole
bunch of different event functions you
can use key ones updates this gets
called every frame and you can do a
whole bunch of work in there to sort of
figure out what it is that's going on
and you've got things like awake and
start for initialization and a whole
ones of others for collision detection
and so forth
looking at the the tower-defense
starter kits that we just have a quick
look at you've got an update method
which is kind of like this there's a lot
going on in there really it needs to
it's being called for every frame so it
could be being called sixty times a
second so the first thing it needs to do
is should I do any work right now so
what this is doing is looking to try and
find something to target try and find
something to shoot at and the first
thing it does is a my doing it of any
work here I'm gonna search a number of
times per second and so it'll figure
that one out
then it'll get the nearest targetable
item if it finds it it will call a
method
sorry call an event acquire target and
then find it'll aim the turret and get
on there this gets called 60 times a
second and it will sort of update as
appropriate serialized fields are a
really useful way of configuring your
your data in your project and every
component can have serialize fields
which allow you to edit your data in the
editor itself so designers can do it
it's not just up to the coder to figure
out exactly how things should be done
and it can be changed at runtime it can
be changed at any time and it can work
like the like you can see here with the
inspector view they're showing
you what's going on and showing your
ways of editing your your data so
basically any public field in a script
component is treated as a serialize
field you can also use attributes to
specify this and you can see on the left
there this this projectile class has
four serialize fields one which is the
throw the art preference the fire mode
the firing angle and the start speed
rider actually sort of picks that
information out and shows it's on the
page for you and you can click through
and navigate to where it's being used
and it gets displayed in the inspector
in unity as you see on the right hand
side there are plenty of other kinds of
script components you can do so things
like UI components buttons and so on
networking scriptable objects which is
just a way of storing serialized data
you can also have editor components this
is really useful because you can
configure the way the editor work for
you in fact if we look at the example
here we've got an edit component for
this particular script object because
we've got four serialize fields but only
three fields in the inspector there so
we've changed the way it works we've
hidden one field we've had in the title
and we're working with that as a editor
components you me and the other thing as
well with my scripting is that it's not
just all about mono behaviors and
components nor that kind of thing you
use plain ol C sharp as well so you can
have your stuff talking to unity and
doing things when it gets called to
update you can go off and use any amount
of c-sharp that you want to go and do
whatever it is that you need to do such
as your artificial intelligence for
targeting and reacting and so on
which brings my slee them to the idea of
libraries great we've got new get we've
got a whole bunch of libraries we can
use and reuse and pull in and well no we
can't really new get isn't supported so
we don't get new gets and that's because
unity works in a different way so new
get is all about sort of assemblies and
sort of you know it's very much sort of
code focused
whereas unity is very much about assets
and again is unity is not focused on the
C sharp world you know to see shops a
very important part of it but it's not
the whole sort of central part there's
an additional question
with unity as what would be the target
framework what is the dll that you would
choose out of a package to target unity
itself but there are ways of working
with us you can still use libraries with
with unity just kind of works a little
bit differently so you can add an
assembly as an asset directly you can
drop it into your assets folder unity
will bring it all in it recognizes it as
a dll and it says fine I will use it as
a reference when I'm compiling things
and use it you can deploy it and it will
still work and everything's fine you can
also create a class library project copy
the dll to assets and work like that's
not terribly convenient though because
unity is in charge of generating all
your solution files and CS profile so
those things tend to be separate so it's
a little bit awkward so generally
speaking if you've got a library you
tend to just use it as source inside
your assets folder which just means that
your ass is fold it gets big and
unwieldy and kind of awkward it's also
slows down the compile cycle because
you've got more work going on there so
one way of working with this is the idea
of assembly definition files which
allows you to split up your assets
folder into separate assemblies and sort
of modularize things a little bit
however things are getting better recent
versions of unity of introduced a
package manager and so there are
packages unfortunately the phrase
package is overloaded within unity so
you've got the idea of the package
manager here and these kinds of packages
but anything you download from the asset
store is also called an asset store
package so it's sometimes a little
tricky to know which kind of package
you're talking about there is work to
bring the asset store packages into this
package manager but that's that's a way
off yet this is all loosely based on on
NPM you got a package Jason and
dependencies and so forth and you can
see a list of packages there and you can
download those it'll fill in any
dependencies you've got and everything
is good once you have the packages
downloaded they are treated as as
read-only they're stored in a local
- they're treated as read-only and you
don't get to edit them one thing which
is really cool about packages though is
that they contain assets so this kind of
fixes the issue with new get just being
about assemblies and packages for unity
can contain any kind of assets so they
can contain images music audio models
and script files as well everything in a
package has a meta file and so they then
get treated essentially just like they
were as though they were in your assets
folder and so it just becomes part of
the asset database added into your
project and it's almost as if they were
part of the assets folder but now it's
nice and separate so you haven't got
that problem of knowing that there's a
bunch of code in there that isn't yours
but you've got to maintain and all that
kind of stuff you can distribute
assemblies in your asset in your
packages but unity suggests that you
actually distribute your code as as
c-sharp files of script files and one of
the sort of main reasons for doing this
is that firstly you can modify them if
you need to and secondly you can it
helps with upgrading so you can target
multiple versions at once with sort of
various defines but you can also when
you upgrade a new version unity will run
and script upgrade across your files and
fix up any api's that are that have
might be modified in that particular
version you can also bring your packages
into the packages folder so if you've
downloaded something which is into
read-only mode you can copy that across
into the packages folder and you get
then get to edit them and work with them
as as though is your own code and you
can also use it for your own code as
well so if you want to create a library
that you want to redistribute you crave
that in the packages folder and then you
just need to zip up that folders to be
able to to distribute okay so um project
files we need to talk about the project
file so if we saw that these would get
generated when you sort of open up a
project I the some of these we've kind
of got more packages here sorry more
project files here than we would have
expected perhaps yeah we've got the
assets folder there but we've got a
whole bunch more project file so where
did those come
well when you use a package then if
you've got no those living in the sort
of packages folder there they become one
or more projects as well so we've got a
few there were sort of unity collections
unity collections tests unity
mathematics and so on but the main ones
really are the assembly c-sharp CS proj
which is all the files in the assets
folder and then we've got assembly C
sharp editor and this one's a little bit
weird and this is all to do with more
magic folders any folder called editor
is magic and basically any file that
lives inside that editor folder gets
copied into or sorry gets referenced by
the assembly c-sharp editor CS project
file these are files that can contain
only editor code so these are things for
editor components if you want to change
the way the inspector works we want to
introduce a new editor window or gizmos
which are sort of little sort of handles
on the design surface which make it
easier to work with your tools they live
inside the editor folders and become
part of the editor projects there are a
few of the magic folders resources
plugins gizmos we don't need to worry
about those but what becomes tricky with
the editor project in the editor folders
is that everything is targeting the
editor anyway so the assembly c-sharp
editor CS prod is for editor files but
all of those files will work exactly the
same if you put them into assembly
c-sharp CS proj so what's the difference
here why why is this this one again was
one of those things that took me a
little while to figure out but the idea
is that anything that is just an editor
components lives inside the editor
project whereas all the other things are
supposed to be runtime components but
runtime components can include editor
code so I can have a script component
which is runtime but then it can add
extra functionality for when it's being
compiled in the editor so it's almost
like debug information so it can be sort
of printing out debug information as it
were to the editor or handles for easily
manipulating things on the design
surface but it is actually still a
runtime component if you need to do that
you have to wrap that in a hash if unity
editor block if you don't do that things
will break when you try and compile your
project and target a standalone player
okay
write versioning versioning is sadly a
little bit more complicated than you'd
hope for the inter versions are fairly
straightforward these days there are
four releases a year based on the the
year itself twenty nineteen point one
point two point three point four the
first three are tech releases the API
can change they'll introduce new
features that kind of thing the dot full
release is the long term support release
which is going to be supported for one
year two years whatever it is and this
is the stable release as it were all of
these versions get get patch releases
maintenance releases and one thing that
is really interesting to note is that
there is culturally a reluctance to
update and to upgrade to a new version
this is because people tend to stick
with a particular version while they're
working on again they want to
concentrate on the game rather than
worry about the upgrade process this
might be because they're using assets
from other people they don't know if
those assets are going to work on the
particular version and so they tend to
just stick with a particular version for
a project and then move up for the next
version typically speaking if you're
starting a project you can start with
the stable version and you know you know
you're going to be good if you know
you've got a long time and you can
factor it in you can start with the
current version and then just upgrade as
you go along it's kind of up to you and
again if you're doing if it's a hobby
reason then you know just use whichever
version you want mano-a-mano makes
things a little bit more complicated so
historically as I say you know all of
your scripting is running on top of mono
it's not running on net cord on a
framework it's all on mono historically
speaking unity was stuck in an old
version of mono for a long time and this
version used to target dotnet to
effectively so it's really quite old he
got stuck on c-sharp for and don't net
to for a very long time I was only with
the first twenty seventeen released that
things got back up to a more modern four
you can't say that it is the current
version of mono though because they have
their own fork so they keep it up to
date now is now sort of equivalent to
the modern version but they have their
own fork with unity specific things and
one of the cool things they've added for
example is in one of the recent versions
they've added an experimental
incremental garbage collector so
normally when you do garbage collection
it stops the whole world does a whole
bunch of work and it starts things off
if you're doing 60 frames a second
that's gonna cause issues if you're not
careful so what they've done is have an
incremental garbage collector which does
chunks of work in between frames and so
your game keeps on playing smoothly and
it takes a little bit longer wall clock
time to do a garbage collector
collection but it should be a whole lot
smoother so basically it should be an up
to date version of mono but it's going
to be slightly different version this
though also means you've got problems
with target framework runtimes versions
and again this would cause problems if
you did bring new get in so previously I
had to use dotnet to now use a dotnet
for equivalent because it is mono you
don't quite know what version of.net for
that is because that's not how mono work
smarter just implements a bunch of api's
and that's kind of dotnet for and you
know hope for the best
that is now the default and the stable
version and but you're still going to
see this kind of littered about in
forums and stuff where people are
talking about which version they're
supporting and which version you should
be targeting to complicate things even
more you got to worry about profiles so
there's a dotnet for profile and a
dotnet standard 2.0 profile donek
standard is the defaults and the idea of
this is the darknet standard is going to
be supported on more platforms
however dotnet 4 gives you more api's so
if you know that you're going to be
working on a small number of platforms
you know such as I'm only going to run
on Windows then you can use the don''t
for one which is more useful if you need
to bring in an external API sorry the
external library which is using an API
that perhaps isn't supported on on a
different target platform but the dona
standard 2 is the default and
you specifically need to don't worry
about it just use it and so then that
brings us on to c-sharp versions
previously we'll stuck on c-sharp for
when you updated mono that brought it up
to c-sharp six as the releases since
then have gone on it's just gone
straight up to c-sharp 7.3 and they're
expected to hit c-sharp 8 anytime now so
we're kind of keeping up to date again
now so again previously you can see it
in forums where people say oh yeah we're
stuck on old versions of c-sharp that's
no longer true you know can I use new
versions of c-sharp building into
projects as we've seen if you're in the
editor you don't need to worry about
anything the editor controls everything
here there's no project files the seat
the editor does everything for you
monitors file changes recompiles reloads
the ab domains and everything is fine
the CS project files are just there for
the IDE s there our API is to make this
a bit more customizable but we don't
tend to need to worry about that things
get a little bit more interesting when
you're building for standalone players
when you actually want to distribute
this and not run it inside the editor
you can build for lots of different
platforms you can have a standalone
player for Windows Mac or Linux for your
tablet devices phone devices and you can
also target consoles and everything
there as well so you can target
PlayStation 4 Xbox one Nintendo switch
but to do that you'd need to be part of
a developer program and that usually
means rather heavy NDA's and nobody ever
talks about that you if you ask them if
they got an NDA they say no so it's it's
crazy as part of the build cycle you're
also going to get projects built for
native tool chains so you tend to have
things need to have things like xcode
installed if you're working for mac and
this is because of an interesting
question which is how does unity support
a new platform if you know how do you
deport mono to every single platform do
you need a wizard who really understands
how the PlayStation 4 works to be able
to generate a JIT for PlayStation 4 what
happens if the platform doesn't support
jetting like in in the phone you know
iPhone and that leads onto a really
crazy piece of technology that unity has
which solves this problem and this is
il-2
cpp which will transpile your compiled
c-sharp files from IL into C++ because
every platform has a C++ compiler so you
don't need to be an expert on porting
mono writing jits you just need to have
a C++ compiler it's fairly boilerplate
translation to to from the il into C++
there but they're also specific
optimizations there which can examine
your code as it's being trans transpiled
and remove some things the debugging
story is nice and easy which is good to
know it's just the mono debugger not
quite as just as that because you've got
a wide range of unity devices and she's
got its own Forks of mono so all these
different versions can cause some
headaches for the debugging teams but
that's again not for us to worry about
that's for the debugging teams to do and
the ID figures out how to connect
everything so if you're using your IDE
they'll automatically configure
everything up for you so you just need
to click the debug button and you're
good to go
D button devices is is fun as well
because mono debugging were is socket
based those sockets can be either local
or remote and so if you've got a device
on the network you just need to point it
at the appropriate socket and it'll just
start working when you run a unity app
on in debug mode on a device it will
broadcast itself via a UDP message and
it gives us all the information you need
to be able to connect to it and so it
just works you can use usb as well to
sort of tunnel this through USB and that
works then across the platforms it even
works with iOS and all those things
using il-2 cpp because not only did they
transpire c p-- il-2 c++ but they wrote
the mono debugger in there as well which
is just you know bonkers um testing so
every test is there c-sharp codes right
yeah yeah you don't do that necessarily
so much in the Unity world it's possible
but it's kind of very much underused and
miss
understood and not really well-known
there is an end unit API they can use
there's got unity specific features so
you can have a unity test attribute on a
method which allows sort of advancing
through frames so you can do a whole
bunch of different tests and over the
years there have been several different
iterations of the API with there's a new
iteration which looks like it's getting
a lot more support from the company and
documentation and it looks like it's
gonna catch on hopefully so hopefully
we'll be able to see more testing but
the big problem really is knowing what
to test and knowing how to test your
game there's very little guidance out
there on actually how you test an
interactive game like this one of the
kind of downsides to unity is that it's
really quite a closed source world so
you don't necessarily write a game and
then put it up on github your write a
game and you ship it and try and make
money off it and so you don't get to see
how other people do things and that
includes testing a couple of important
things know about testing though is that
tests must run inside a unity process so
the unity remember the the unity is and
I've got a native core and eventually
everything goes down and sort of P
invokes into the native world if you try
and run it in any unit console it'll
fail because that native world isn't
there and so generally speaking if you
try and use an IDE or an e in a console
it will fail and you have to run it
through the Unity process two different
modes of running edit mode and play mode
edit mode is all about testing your edge
editor components you're running as
though you're running it's in the editor
you can switch in and out you can switch
your game in you know how to sort of
play mode but it's all about testing the
actual editor extension themselves you
have play mode tests as well the game is
only in play mode you can't switch it
into editor mode and the interesting
thing here is you can run these tests on
device as well so you can tell any unity
to run it on the device which is pretty
useful and then of course just a little
plug for writer because we made rider
talk to the unity process so it runs the
tests
unity process but we report it inside
inside
rider itself so if you want to be doing
testing sort of seamlessly through your
IDE give rider a go small plugs all
right last couple of things then
profiling is obviously very very
important because performance is is
everything in the Unity world unity
ships with a massive profiler which is
deep profiling lots of information it
covers the entire stack not just your
code so it'll tell you what your CPU is
doing the GPU do is doing how the
rendering threads are working what the
native threads are doing and a whole
bunch of stuff this can sometimes be a
bit of information overload
so again Ryder with another of the plug
is very helpful and we've got dot trace
inside Ryder working with unity and so
we can do a code focused profiling of
your code there as well and their
various inspections which kind of call
out sort of performance related stuff
for you very last thing then is
something that's new the data oriented
tech stack which is a new architecture
so everything I've told you so far about
this game objects and components they're
starting to move away from this but it's
only very slow this is still very very
new they're not recommending people use
this in production yet but this is this
is what the future is going to be
they'll have migration paths in place
hopefully to be able to use this better
in the future
the problem is with game objects and
components is this is really really bad
for doing things in bulk so if you have
a game with a thousand enemies and you
want to move a thousand enemies you have
to look up a thousand game objects and
for each game object you have to go and
get the transform component update it
move on to the next one and so forth
everything being some spread out like
that is really bad you kind of have lots
of cache misses as you're loading data
in and you just can't get the
performance so the idea for this is the
data that changes together is stored
together so you end up with an array of
enemy positions and you just walk across
the whole array and set them all and
that's it and by doing that you can sort
of take advantage of
this thing they've got which is the
burst compiler which is a
post-processing sort of optimizer
effectively which will auto vectorize
your code so it uses a whole there's a
whole bunch of things in parallel can do
things concurrently and it's a pretty
nifty stuff and it's working nicely now
so they're actually starting to migrate
some of their native code into manage
code because this burst compiler can do
things better and faster than they can
do in the sort of in the native world
which is cool
there is a megacity demo which they have
done if you just serve google for unity
and megacity then you'll get to see that
this kind of demo here which has got
millions of objects running at once and
it's all running nicely and then they
show on a phone as well so this this is
a nice way of working and it's pretty
cool but that's not for now that's for
the future and game objects and
components will pretty much get to you
everywhere and that kind of is brings me
to the end of what I wanted to show you
and hopefully you kind of covered a
whole bunch of things there which are
not necessarily going to be obvious
inside the tutorials but will give you a
good grounding then to go on and learn
those tutorials and things will make a
bit more sense there should be some you
know holds things like meta files which
are obviously very very important you
need now need to sort of know why
they're important why you need to have
those across in your source control and
never ever lose them next steps would be
to go off and actually search for
tutorials and go and get hands-on and
give those a go and use the asset store
get some free models get assets and so
on and also the starter kits which are a
nice way to see how you do some of these
things and of course Deborah havoc on
unity for Ryder which will give you a
lot of hints and tips as well for how to
use that kind of thing I'm at the
JetBrains booth as well for the next for
the rest of the week if you have any
questions or want to see a demo of any
of the sort of unity type stuff feel
free come on by other than that thank
you for attention we've got a few
minutes for questions if anybody has any
nope okay well thank you very much for
coming
time for the boat cruise